going back to the wireframes in the
phone layout we wanted the today item to
be a little bit bigger but on the
tablets we just want it to look like all
the other items because we have an
expanded detail pane here to do this and
the forecast adapter new view method we
should return the layout for a list item
forecast not for the today layout then
in the bind view method for the today
item we should use the gray icon instead
of the colored icon these decisions get
controlled by the return value of the
get item view type method therefore we
modify the get item view type method so
that at the 0th position if we have to
use the special 2-day layout then we
return view type today otherwise if we
shouldn't use the special today layout
then we should just return the view type
for all future days this boolean is
controlled by the setter method to
access this boolean we've created a
public setter method on the forecast
adapter but who knows how to set this
value properly well the mainactivity
knows whether it's one pain or two-pane
UI so it can decide whether we should
use the special today layout or not we
don't have access to the forecast
adapter here but we can plumb the value
through the forecast fragment to get
access to the forecast fragment we can
ask the fragment manager and pass it the
fragment ID finish changing the codes of
the app looks like this